Speaker 1: Republicans are now claiming both
some kind of vindication and some kind of
cover up, because President Joe Biden has
ordered a closer intelligence review of the
origins of the covid-19 virus and pandemic.
And Biden revealed that earlier this year,
per CNBC, he asked the intelligence community
to assess did it emerge from human contact
with an infected animal or did it emerge from
a laboratory accident?
Increasingly, there are more and more people
saying we need to study whether this was manmade.
And it's really important to understand that
these are different ideas and that there is
not a current belief that covid was manmade.
And in fact, if it were based on the best
medical science I've read, it would have a
different sort of signature that would be
noticeable when you examine the virus.
Now, let's let's really understand what is
going to be examined here, which I think is
great.
And by the way, those claiming that the left
never wanted to look at this, go talk to the
people who said that.
I have said from the very beginning, investigate
everything.
We want truth.
I want truth.
But regardless, the idea persists that the
left doesn't want to know the truth.
I very much want to know the truth.
So option one, contact spread to humans from
an animal to humans likely and human and spread
from there.
Scenario number two, this came from an animal
and was being studied in a lab, possibly in
Wuhan, and due to an accident, it leaked and
spread there to the worldwide human population.
And then you have scenario three, the most
conspiratorial and the one for which we have
no evidence, which is this was some kind of
a human made bioweapon that was deliberately
released into the wild by China.
Now, that first piece doesn't really pass
the sniff test, in part because it has been
so damaging not only to China but to other
countries around China that China has no reason
to try to go after.
So the U.S. centric nationalist view is China
would have been motivated to do this in order
to attack the U.S.
Most of the deaths have been elsewhere.
I think globally, officially, there are about
three point five, three point six million
covid deaths.
And in the U.S. there's officially 600000.
That means that five sixth of the deaths were
elsewhere and many in China very would be
very, very strange thing to do.
Now, as a reminder of the Biden administration
has been OK investigating this for a long
time.
Here is White House Deputy Press Secretary
Koreen Jean-Pierre two days ago saying the
Biden administration has not ruled anything
out and is open to exploring further.
Speaker 2: Another question on covid.
The language that you all use specifically
mentioned an accident.
Does that mean that you've ruled out or the
IOC has ruled out that it was deliberate or
not an accident?
Speaker 3: We haven't ruled out anything yet.
Again, we're going to go through this, you
know, is redoubling down of another of a 90
day review and we'll have more to share.
Speaker 1: But yet the idea will not go away
that Joe Biden doesn't want to investigate
this.
Remember, this is from earlier this week.
We looked at these clips.
This is from Monday.
Here is Peter Doocy from FOX News asking White
House Press Secretary Jen Psaki.
But why won't Joe Biden look into it?
What will it take for him to look into it?
Speaker 3: New investigation, but with
Speaker 4: five hundred eighty nine thousand
nine hundred twenty dead Americans.
At what point does President Biden say, we
don't want to wait for the WHL?
We don't know what they're doing?
This needs to be an American led effort to
get to the bottom of what happened.
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, we need access
to the underlying data and information in
order to have that investigation.
Speaker 4: And but he tossed all the time
about how he's known President Xi for a long
time.
So why can't you just
Speaker 3: and and we need them for that information.
I think you're misunderstanding how this process
actually works.
An international investigation led by the
World Health Organization is something that
we've actually been pressing for for several
months in coordination with a range of partners
around the world.
We need that data.
We need that information from the Chinese
government.
What we can't do and what I would caution
anyone doing is leaping ahead of an actual
international process.
We don't have enough data and information
to jump to a conclusion at this point in time.
Speaker 4: So is there any amount of casualties
from covid in this country that would make
you want to not wait for an international
effort and just do it as well?
Speaker 3: I have to say, I think the family
members of the loved ones whose lives have
been lost and deserve accurate information
data, not the jumping to a conclusion without
having the information necessary to conclude
with the origins are what we do share everyone
in this country as a desire to know how this
started, where it started, and prevent it
from ever happening again.
That's something we all share.
Go ahead.
Speaker 1: And then not satisfied, I guess,
with that answer, asking the same question
on Tuesday and getting a very similar answer.
Speaker 4: This president buying these theories
we hear more about now that covid-19 may have
been manmade in this heat from a lab in China
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based on
what he has heard and been briefed on, does
he think that's possible?
Speaker 3: Well, we went through this journey
together yesterday, so let's do it again.
So the president believes there needs to be
an independent investigation, one that's run
by the international community.
It's an international pandemic that has killed
hundreds of thousands of people around the
world.
He believes the Chinese need to do more to
put forward data to be more transparent.
And in the second phase of this effort, he's
certainly hopeful that will be the case.
And he believes that every theory should be
explored through that process, but that we
shouldn't jump to conclusions before that
data and that information is made available.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: And on the right side.
So, listen, there's really no reason not to
do this, whether or not it was engineered,
as some conspiracists claim, although we have
no evidence for that at this point in time.
Why wouldn't we want to find out more about
the origins of an infectious disease that
became a global pandemic, completely overtook
us and created the chaos that it did over
the last 16, 17 months.
So, again, the best science I've read is that
had it been.
Engineered by humans, it could not have been
done with any of the known tools of genetic
manipulation.
OK, when you use the known tools from genetic
manipulation, they leave evidence in the genome
that's not there.
So, again, applying some sort of Occam's razor
here, if this was engineered, it was engineered
in a way that it was done with heretofore
unknown methods such that engineering is unable
to be detected.
That's a big leap and we don't have any evidence
of that.
Investigated, investigated.
One was researching bat borne coronaviruses
and classifying them and looking at mutation
rates and behaviors.
So is it possible attack got scratched while
they were working with these samples?
It's plausible, certainly, and it should be
investigated.
The wet market hypothesis from the beginning,
quite plausible.
Let's let's investigate it.
But the idea, the fake scandal, now that the
right is trying to create that the left is
unwilling to explore it or that the left is
covering it up, or that this is somehow Dr.
Foundry's fault, he was involved in the creation
to then make money from the Solutia.
There is no evidence for any of those things.
And absent that evidence, we should just be
saying, investigate, do an investigation.
Now, I saw a couple kind of weird comments
from some claiming to be on the left, saying
the lab leak hypothesis is racist because
it implies that Chinese scientists are just
incompetent.
Come on, guys, we're we're getting nowhere
with that trash, OK?
Accidents can happen anywhere.
For all we know, it's not even all Chinese
scientists that were working in that lab,
it's that we're going down a really dumb path
to say even exploring this is racist.
Even raising the question is racist.
That's nuts.
Assuming that it was any of these things,
though, until we actually have some evidence,
that's also not going to make any sense to
me.
Send me your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman.